Paris
canaille Paris Marl aux yeux de fille
ton les chilou tes vieilles guenill mais
tu es galante accordéon ça fait pas de
rente mais c'est si bon tu es gigolo
tuas les habilles sur le métro de la
Bastille pour se saouler à tes jupons ça
fait gueuler mais c'est siibon
de ça fait Peet qui font merveille ene
saison ça
fait ça fait
son
[Musique]
Rais pour la chronique traction avant
pour la tactique un petit coup che dans
le diapason range tes copèes sinon tu es
bon à la Une à la de f-moi trois tunes
je te verrai mieux ta toute dernière des
éditions tu es en galère Mons c'est
siibon à lad à rien tu un gangster à la
de faut être à droite pour faire carton
la prochaine fois tu sera peut-être
bon Paris j'aib à la voix grise
le long des rues tu vocalises il y a pas
d'espoir dans haons seulement
trattoir mais c'est si
bon
vagabond te font des scènes mais sous
tes pont coule la scène pour la
romance
illusion
l'affluence mais c'est si
bon mon m égaré dans les faub bourgs pr
PAV pousse l'amour ça pousse encore à la
maison on a eu t mais c'est si bon
regarde perdu dans les ruour la rue
comme un bâau ça tue un peu dans
l'entrapon c'est laborieux mais c'est si
bon
Paris flon flon la main fait et des
millions poures poètes quelques
chentimes à ma chanson ça fait la RIM et
c'est si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon